once on a time the Fox was talking to
the wolf about the strength of man how
no animal could ever withstand him and
how all were obliged to employ cunning
in order to preserve themselves from him
then the wolf answered if I had but the
chance of seeing man for once I would
set upon him all the same
I can help you do that said the Fox come
to me early in the morning and I shall
show you a man the wolf presented
himself early and the Fox took him out
to the road by which the hunters came
daily first came an old discharged
soldier is that a man inquired the wolf
no on to the Fox that was once a man
afterwards came a little boy who was
going to school is that a man no there's
going to be a man at length came a
hunter with a double-barreled gun at his
back in a knife by his side said the Fox
to the wolf look there comes a man you
must attack him but first I will take
myself off to my hole the wolf then
rushed on the man when the hunter saw
him he said it is a pity that I have not
loaded of a bullet he aimed and fired
the wolf made a very wry face but did
not allow himself to be frightened and
attacked him again on which the hunter
gave him the second barrel the wolf
swallowed his pain and rushed on the
hunter once again but he drew out his
bright knife and he gave him a few cuts
with it right and left so there bleeding
everywhere
he ran howling back to the fox's hole
well brother wolf said the Fox how have
you got on with the man ah replied the
wolf I never imagined the strength of
man to be what it is first he took a
stick from his shoulder and blew into it
and then something flew into my face
which tickled me terribly
then he breathed once more into the
stick and it flew into my nose like
lightning and hail when I was quite
close he drew a white rib from his side
and beat me with it till I was all but
left lying dead you see what a braggart
you are said the Fox you have
overreached yourself you have thrown
your hatchet so far that you cannot
fetch it back
the tale of the man in the wolf is a
fairly short story but there is more
than meets the eye it's not just a
simple tale of a wolf attacking a man in
this story we have one party learning a
lesson while being observed by another I
mean how many times have you told a
friend or family member not to do
something only to watch them do it
anyway
completely disregarding your warning we
have the Fox who is clearly quite clever
and essentially understands its position
in the food chain
man is very clearly the ultimate
predator and the Fox does not wish to
challenge this fact the wolf however is
far more prideful and refuses to listen
to the Fox boasting that if he ever came
across a man he would set upon him the
Fox predicting the outcome teaches the
wolf a lesson by taking him to a man and
watching as the wolf fails miserably in
his attempts to overpower the man there
are a few meanings and lessons I took
away from this story the first being to
know your surroundings and limitations
which will in turn stop you overreaching
in the same ways the wolf did the second
theme being that you never really know
how you will react in any given
situation until you are placed in that
very situation you may know yourself
pretty well but if you don't know the
situation it's almost impossible to say
the wolf for example is undoubtedly
aware that it's a very strong animal but
it boasts about been in the situation
then it's never been in before
completely disregarding the advice and
experience of the Fox and this becomes
evident in the fact that the Fox has to
point out to the wharf what a man even
looks like the wolf being aware of his
own strength was clearly non enough in
this situation as he was not prepared
for the man's gun or knife and it almost
lost his life as a result the message
here seems to be quite simple do not
brag about how you would react in
scenarios that you've never been in
before and listen to those who have been
in them I hope you guys enjoyed this
story I thought it was quite an
interesting tale of man versus nature
with quite a useful set of morals and
lessons to learn let me know what you
guys thought in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]